happy Sunday reject nation we're gonna
talk about movie news because we know
there's about five people who like
watching these videos why not satisfy
them before doing that I want her to say
thank you to screen junkies for inviting
me on to movie fights I hadn't been on
an about two and a half years and when I
last went on I didn't do a good job I
had good choices terrible arguments I
didn't know really the approach on how
to take down other people's choices and
whatnot and apparently I don't want you
anything away but according to Dan Merle
I might have made a little bit of movie
fights history on this last match I went
on so he's the fact-checking guy you go
to go check out the latest movie fights
episode
what should Star Wars do after that I
forget the title of it it's his latest
movie fights episode I had a great time
on there Josh mokuba how rudnick Yale I
forget her last name but we're really
appreciate you guys to go check it out
because I put a lot of work into that
anyway let's move on to some movie news
of the week so let's get the comic quick
ones out of the way first cuz they're
actually pretty much comic book ones
except for the last one I just threw in
here Penguin has been rumored to play
the villain in the next Batman movie now
the two stories go like this
Oswald Cobblepot will either play the
villain in the Batman movie that Matt
Reeves is supposedly doing is he is a
it's been a long time heard no update
kind of forgot about this one and
there's also the birds of prey movie
which should have Harley Quinn in there
as well rumored Batgirl rumored Catwoman
I would prefer the penguin to be in the
Batman movie if I'm gonna make a choice
here because he is a criminal mastermind
this guy and I actually rewatched Batman
Returns a week or two ago and I I didn't
like that movie growing up are we
watching it now I was like you know I
kind of love this movie and I think
Danny DeVito's performance of penguin is
pretty fantastic stuff I have been doing
a TV show watch along her patreon for
Gotham and I love the young portrayal of
penguin in that show and I think that if
you kind of can any
those you know penguins supernatural
elements that were in Batman Returns and
you stick to criminal mastermind I think
that would be a great choice for Batman
to go up against penguin in that
scenario we haven't gotten a great
live-action version of that yet where
it's that man and Penguin going
toe-to-toe and it wouldn't be some
supernatural villain he's going up
against it could be a grounded Matt
Reeves venture and Batman taking on a
lot of you know penguin goons and you
know henchmen it's does you still get
some cool action scenes in there birds
of prey I especially think if you have
Catwoman like if you throw in birds of
prey which already has all these Batman
characters and then you have penguin one
of Batman's main villains in there and
you don't have Batman in it I would kind
of get annoyed by that'd be a weird
situation I feel like there's all this
right now with separating the villains
from the heroes and kind of yeah mixing
things and on places and for me I guess
what I would hope for from this Batman
movie that I also forgot about is I
would love to see yeah the criminal
mastermind element played up and then
met with Batman as the detective like I
want to see the detective and martial
arts bang yeah go up with the criminal
mastermind penguin because while mmmm
Returns had elements of that in terms of
like the last time we saw penguin on the
big screen it was still like weird he
lived in the sewer you know he had a
bunch of penguin follow orders it's a
good tie it's cool like it worked for
that movie but I think for a realistic
approach that would be cool and Josh GAD
has been like kind of putting himself
out there wanting to play the penguin I
think he could actually do a pretty good
job at that and that would be fun to see
him take on a bit of a weighty role to
you know bring his comedic chops and his
craziness but also the acting he could
bring to that definitely definitely so I
don't know what do you guys think which
one would you want paying would it be in
Batman or birds of prey hands-down
everyone says birds of prey I guess the
biggest story this week is Blum houses
Oh spawn movie Blum how it's taking on
spawn just hearing that I'm like cool
I'll watch that door
especially because Blum house has a
reputation effort so many directors say
that Blum house just lets them do what
they want
yeah that's the most common threat I've
heard with all the directors is they
don't interfere the only thing that they
might have a discussion with jason blum
about is we need a little more money
yeah it's not really an argument of
creative differences and todd mcfarlane
the guy created spawn is actually
directing and writing this next spawn
movie which gets me excited cuz how
often you get to see that not since like
Frank Miller working on Sin City have we
gotten something as cool as that yeah
and his worrisome is that can be for
some people I think that is a really
cool thing for spawn is for the
landscape of superhero comic book movies
in general to go you know to the Blum
House kind of mode of the spectrum you
know having said probably a little more
micro-budget but that will have a
totally different palette from all the
other ones yeah and I think with Jamie
Foxx on a spawn that was like cool news
to me I wasn't exactly jacked about that
what got me excited was when Todd
McFarlane released a statement saying
why he wanted Jamie Foxx for it I think
we have a quote here actually Jamie came
to my office five years ago and he had
an idea about spawn and we talked about
it I never forgot him when I got done
and my agents and everybody was talking
about what actor I said I'm going to
Jamie first and until he says no I don't
want to think about anyone else because
I've never had anyone else on my head
luckily he hadn't forgotten either
that's cool like for the creator of
spawn to have a conversation with an
actor who seemed passionate about an
idea for spawn and for five years to
hold on to just this idea and for Jamie
Foxx to be like absolutely yeah like for
the creator to be excited about what
this actor had to offer the conception
of how this came to be would creator and
actor are coming together for this is
what gets me most excited about it
because you know Jamie Foxx deserves a
shot at having a cool comic book
character that we all know about the
whole electro deal that went down out
that didn't go well not really his fault
I think a cool comic book-y yeah I mean
Chris Evans got to have his shot with
Captain America after Fantastic Four and
Scott Pelley then Scott Pilgrim Michael
B Jordan after Fantastic Four I got to
have kill monger Ryan Reynolds with his
countless companies got to have
Deadpool now why not give Jamie Fox this
shot it doesn't just seem like some cool
casting it seemed like this was the
vision I had and I want to Jamie Foxx
specifically yeah and that enthusiasm is
what makes me excited about this project
overall it's just the idea that you know
they got the creator to helm this and
the idea that Jamie Foxx and him really
want to work together on this I feel
like that passion is gonna create
something magical absolutely and you
know I mean I like Michael Jai White but
to see Jamie Foxx take on the role you
know with his chops and whatnot I'm
excited to see what he does both out of
the makeup and in it you know alright so
next story here is TV news the last time
I saw The Walking Dead was season 8
episode 1 when it had an all-right
opener but it really hit me that this
show is gonna pull some of the same
[ __ ] obviously I was just what I
realized I was watching it I just gave
up yeah we have to like season 6 I'm
partway through there and just hearing
about the decisive turn the show I don't
know continue I've never actually seen a
show and had that breaking point where I
was like okay I'm I don't think I'm
gonna watch this anymore yeah right it's
weird and I used to love this show so
much yeah like I used to be all about it
and then now if there was any more
reason to not continue the show only
character that like I like Daryl's sure
and I like deny guerreras Michonne sure
I like Carol but there's only one
character I love yeah there's only one
actor who I'm like man this show just
would not work without him even when the
show doesn't work I love one yeah Andrew
Lincoln planning on exiting after season
9 which it's I don't blame the guy the
show's dipping he arguably gets the most
emotionally challenging stuff to do on
this show it's also a very physically
demanding show nine seasons is about
what ten years that's a lot and for a
guy who has this much talent I want to
see him do other work I like that his
actual speaking voice isn't the southern
accent that he's actually British choral
dad alone means this guy's definitely
got range just knowing that fact that
he's a British guy
you can do an amazing southern accident
where you think that's his actual
speaking voice you only saw the one you
see in an interview you're like what
yeah if you see him in like other works
because he lacks because the Rick Grimes
look is very specific now there's like
the longer hair the beard that's the
look that we associated way more with as
opposed to how we looked in like the
first couple seasons is I feel like this
guy can transition into movies now or
some other works of television if he
just changes his look up doesn't it that
weird Keanu Reeves thing or it looks
like John distracting back to the
Walking Dead I've heard they're trying
to get Norman Reedus to really stick a
rather they're offering to pay him like
20 million dollars at Norman Reedus his
work as an actor he's a really good
actor he's a little bit more into a
corner I think of the kind of roles he
can do like when it comes to range for
Norman Reedus you prefer to see him in
something like a Daryl obviously whereas
I think Andrew Lincoln has more
potential to branch out even if you keep
Norman Reedus on there he's always just
been the supporting player to me you
need a commanding lead and Andrew
Lincoln is the commanding lead yeah I
feel like this is not gonna bode well
with Walking Dead fans they killed off
Carl spoilers yeah a lot of people
because it's so far from the comics and
then it was like well at least we got
Rick and now he's leaving he's the heart
of the show and to lose him this makes
me go I could care less about this show
now I kinda just want to watch these in
nine just to see his exit yeah that's
that's probably hand like it'll be a
drag for all the move of the season but
the last episode will be great the first
one will be - if I like Daryl - and I
feel like they are gonna have to really
beef that character somehow in order to
make him yeah the compelling lead of
this show and I honestly don't know what
that mean I feel like The Walking Dead
is gonna end soon unless this new
showrunner cuz they're getting another
new showrunner yeah really turns it
around and taps whatever they've been
searching for for three he's heard fear
The Walking Dead is amazing now but no
one really talks about that show unless
you like like already The Walking Dead
no it really talks about fear The
Walking Dead somebody once described
that to me as to show you watch because
you are
walking yeah that's the only thing I
hear about that show is oh it got good
nobody really talks about it other than
leaving alright good luck on your career
buddy walking dead excited to see your
show tank some more no no no he's going
out from this show and he's gonna do a
bunch of low-budget zombie movies it's
gonna be another comic book news
Roseanne has been canceled oh yeah boy
this is quite an interesting journey for
me to have witness what I heard Roseanne
was coming back on the air I thought
that was cool because before what I
heard about that my girlfriend
introduced me to the Roseanne show and I
made it up to with like season three
it's a funny show it's like a heart I
don't see any sitcoms like it today
where it's just about watching a lower
class family try to make it by they're
kind of trailer trash you know way but
they're not like annoying or grossly you
know they're relatable and like they're
always struggling to make the bills this
is a real family and a dynamic between
Roseanne and John Goodman is so special
in that show and I had heard for years
how the show ended like the last season
something about because some book
Roseanne was writing and John Goodman's
character was actually dead so when I
heard they were bringing it back and the
feather they got Laurie Metcalf coming
off an Oscar nomination John Goodman who
has become one of the most respected
actors working a day and you're getting
a lot of the og cast back and they're
gonna course correct that terrible
ending that have said so many fans that
was so exciting but of course Roseanne
in her real life is kind of a racist
[ __ ] a little bit you know it's like
I'm not gonna even ding her on the whole
hardcore Trump thing she just says a lot
of stuff that gets way out of hand and
there are even people on the show really
yeah we got to kind of be aware that
something could go wrong with this show
yeah all it takes is a tweet nowadays
and that's all it took yeah I mean it
doesn't really affect the president but
it will affect everyone else outside the
president for Yankees nobody knows what
to do about that there is a former
person who worked for Obama and you made
a race
comparison yeah use an ape comparison
which is horribly racist
Roseanne's excuse was that she was on
pills that night she had been drinking
and she also said that she didn't
realize this person was black if you see
the photo of Valerie Jarrett I can
understand if you're not like a hundred
percent sure if that person is black or
not still it's like I don't know takes
some responsibility something arose in
you have a nationally broadcast TV show
you can't just be like I took some pills
well she did take responsibility she
said that she actually went to the ABC
execs and begged and said she'll do
anything to make sure these people can
still have the show she'll do like a
bunch of like publicity tours and just
make as much apologies as necessary like
she'll do whatever it takes to make this
right cuz she owned up to the fact of
what she did was wrong ABC did cancel
the show which is kind of interesting
because it was their most popular show
yeah it became their most popular show
and because of a tweet they took the
moral high ground and we can't be
supporting this person then there's the
arguments to be made of well maybe you
picked up the show already you kind of
knew who Roseanne already was and propor
so there's that discussion is ABC really
that cool no wonder they had a guy just
in the corner with his finger over the
button just in case anything happens
like cancel it at the end of the day of
the show has her name in the title she
is the star of it people are talking
about having the John Goodman show just
called a Dan well then you're gonna do
that whole thing that upset them whose
hand fancy kill enough Dan yeah I feel
like once you take out a key element and
the key element I don't I don't think
you can really reconfigure it any
satisfying way for people there's always
gonna be a void there I think the most
upsetting part of this as someone who
only just started the Roseanne show this
year is what this does for fans like
really think about it in the emotional
aspect there's a show you watch it's
amazing you love it and then there's an
ending to it that's just so upsetting
and you just wish they didn't do that
ending and then the show comes back they
course corrective of bringing Dan back
the Rosanne fans are happy for a few
weeks now the show doesn't even have an
ending because they just cancelled it
Midway after yeah at least before it had
an ending it was a crappy ending no less
now it's ended with an even worse taste
because of who real-life Roseanne is and
all the fans will now know who real-life
Roseanne is and it's ruined a great show
that's the problem you ruined a great
show and it's a drag cuz like I know
that some of her beliefs are challenging
to people and on the other hand I kind
of appreciated that she's got these
beliefs as she's being represented as a
part of the spectrum in the
entertainment bubble yeah and she worked
with people who like she's the whole
writing staff for liberals and then a
lot of people on the cast didn't share
her political beliefs so people still
loved her like loved working with her so
it wasn't like oh you're Republican you
sucked it was still like you could be a
Republican and still have the respect of
the people you were yeah we can make
this piece of art together yeah and
still bring everybody the show that they
love and I thought that was kind of
special in a weird way but yeah I'm not
surprised it ended up like this I guess
anyway you guys happy Roseanne's
canceled do the real rejects followers
even give a [ __ ] about this that's
neither for the Christopher Plummer
reboot yeah let us know alright guys
well thank you to the five of you for
watching you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and also check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
s music video coverage would love to
have you become a patron check today I
am about to hop out to a TV show right
now